sharp objects Bowser with an incredible
twist ending now has seen many viewers
react in different ways whilst it may
have had some people immediately turning
off those who stuck around were treated
to a mid credit scene revealed more
about the seasons mystery throughout
this video I'll be discussing the ending
of sharp objects as well as the
post-credits scene so there will be
heavy spoilers without the way I'm
definition and this is my sharp objects
ending explain video sharp objects
reveals many things about the
inhabitants of the town windgap the
majority of the population are either
killers or are in on the murders
themselves and by the finale we are led
to suspect both Camille's mother
adora and Camille's half-sister Auma as
the season comes to a head we learn the
hammer has manipulated adora into taking
the rap for the two murders that her
daughter committed whilst this is very
sadistic just how manipulative Amma is
gets hammered home when we witness her
murdering an Natalie and her new friend
Mei at the close of the show we also get
a glance at two girls helping her commit
the crimes and eagle-eyed viewers will
instantly recognize that it is her two
rollerblading buddies Kelsey and jokes
this makes sense as Emma would have had
to have had help when carrying out some
of the murders and moving the bodies
which these two probably aided in the
post-credits scene is interlaced with
shots of the murder of an Natalie in may
and it also contains an image of an a
dressed in white beckoning her friends
into the woods and to their deaths
this harkens back to the opener of the
finale in which Emma was dressed as
Persephone queen of the underworld I
mentioned earlier that Persephone
relished death and this pushed her away
from mortals in her head amer is now the
queen of death carrying out her destiny
similar to this isolation that
Persephone faced Camille now knows of
her sister's true nature and this will
obviously drive a huge wedge between
them something that will no doubt have a
huge effect on Amer as she stated that
she has trouble sleeping when not
accompanied by Camille will her wish to
become an angel of death mean that she
drives all those who love her away or
will she continue on her manipulative
streak we will have to wait to find out
so what did you think of sharp
Jax did you stick around for the
post-credits scene and what did you take
from it comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and subscribe to my
channel I create content like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of TV recently I discuss
the ending of the new Netflix horror
selfie from hell and what I took from
the film so make sure you check that out
next thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace